من بعد ساعات من الصمت والامتناع عن
التغريد وترقب الناس لحسابه بخصوص اعلان
تنحيه خرج الى الماسك عن صمته وفجر مفاجاه
جديده للناس فبينما لكل جالس منتظر قرار
تنحي كون هو اللي نشر استطلاع انه يتنحى
او لا وصوت اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص مع قرار
انه يتنحى وكان هو قبلها وعد الناس انه
راح يلتزم بنسائج هذا الاستطلاع اللي هو
حطوه طلع له وقال انه ملتزم بنتائج
الاستطلاع بس ما راح يتنحها الا لما نلاقي
شخص احمق كفايه علشان يستلم رئاسه تويتر
بداله وقال انه بعدها راح هو يدير فقط
البرمجيات والخواتم فقط وطبعا التغريده
اللي نشرها ماسك واعلن فيها هذا القرار ما
كانت اول تغريده بيعلق فيها على مجرى
التصويت اللي واضح ما كان ماشي في صالحه
فهو في الاول رد على احد متابعينه واللي
يقول انه من المثير مقارنه عدد الاصوات
بعدد الاعجابات لانه بيطرح السؤال هل سيطر
بس على نتائج الاستطلاع وفورا رد عليه
ماسك انه هذه ملاحظه مثيره للاهتمام